a careful examination of the period from
1873 to 1896 provides useful insight
into our current era of political
division and social separation after the
Civil War America's economic expansion
was halted by the long depression the
longest contraction in US history
coinciding with the society influx is
America transition from an agricultural
Republic to an industrialized nation
political parties at the presidential
level remained unchanged but at the
Congressional level politics became
increasingly destabilized as we still
fought over the Civil War this is much
like today with candidates litigating
issues that have been fought for the
past 40 years change is seen in the
parties over the past few decades will
not be short-lived we are living in an
era of social upheavals when citizens
are constructing new social orders and
our parties are shifting to address
these upheavals the trend towards
populism within the GOP and leftism in
the Democratic Party are symptoms of
these changes and are unlikely to abate
what do you think about the changes in
America's political parties let us know
in the comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI